[Musique]
depuis le 16 juin les députés de la
commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 auditionne des
acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi ancien ministre et
directeur généraux de la santé tout
l'été elle cp vous fait revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui suite et fin de
celle du numéro deux du ministère de la
santé
jérôme salle home au visage désormais
bien connue des français puisqu'il a
présenté chaque soir les points presse
relatif à l'évolution de l'épidémie
il s'est expliqué durant plus de quatre
heures sur la manière dont la direction
générale de la santé avait géré la crise
sanitaire
on écoute dès à présent la deuxième
partie de son audition n'a besoin ce
stade de d'être très précis et je ne me
retrouve pas cette précision dans votre
réponse sur ce qui s'est passé sur la
diminution du stock en 2018 en 2019 le
26 septembre 2018 le professeur stahl
vous dit dix sont dédiés santé publique
france qui vous rédige une note à la dgs
il faut un milliard de masques le 3
octobre
vous avez une note de santé publique
france qui vous dit sur les 600 millions
de max existants 60% ne peuvent pas être
ne peuvent plus être utilisées et vous
vous réagissez le 30 octobre vous
ordonnez 50 millions de masques avec une
option de 50 millions pourquoi alors
qu'on sait qu'il faut un milliard
conseils sur les 600 millions presque
les deux tiers sont inutilisables vous
en recommander à peine 50 aller voir 100
millions 2018 on à 754 millions de
masques chirurgicaux
c'est en 2018 conte à la découverte de
l' expertise en en octobre que
l'essentiel de ce stock est constitué de
masques
très anciens 2003 2005 sans date de
péremption rien et avec une qualité
médiocre dont il y a deux conséquences
premièrement la commande que je fais en
octobre en disant il faut remonter ce
niveau 100 millions je vais 100 millions
en 10 ans 50 et 50 en fait ça fait ça
fait 100 millions
et puis et puis de la même façon de
mettre en place et s'est demandé pour
2020 une nouvelle façon de travailler
parce que le 1 milliard dormant ne
satisfaisait person au sens que personne
ne l'utilisait et que c'était quand même
à mon sens utile qu'ils puissent être
utilisés en particulier par les
établissements de santé les
professionnels de santé mais c'est une
organisation totalement différent trains
met en place et donc effectivement il ya
ces commandes qui surtout on est dépassé
et sont arrivés 2019 et même je crois
début 2020 et une destruction qui a été
qui a été fait en 2019 qui explique
évidemment cette diminution même si on
n'arrive pas à 100 millions puisque je
me le dit tout à l'heure il y avait les
117 millions plus ceux de 2019 plus ce
qu'ils étaient encore disponibles et que
nous avons fait évaluer pour lui
d'utiliser pour le grand public pourriez
vous s'il vous plaît lorsque vous
évoquerez à nouveau des masques ont
incité beaucoup beaucoup de chiffres
nous précise à chaque fois de quel type
de masque je voudrais envira
l'organisation de l'état comment ces
masques ces quantités vous avez évoquées
sont ils distribués sur ce sujet
particulier des masses est-ce que vous
avez personnellement des regrets et
lesquels sur les stocks stratégiques sur
la quantité de 754 millions en 2018 la
découverte d'une forte péremption et
d'une dégradation importante de ce stock
dormant
on parle de masques chirurgicaux il y
avait plus de masques ffp2 depuis
plusieurs années dans le stock
là encore pour des raisons concrètes
ainsi que les masques ffp2 sont des
masques vraiment de d'actes invasifs
d'actes à risque au plus près des
soignants et des services qui en ont
besoin
la fin janvier c'est des rapatriements
de
deux français du web donc nous voulions
avoir un accueil parfait avec des
équipes je vous rappelle qu'ils étaient
des équipes de réservistes qui
s'occupait de nos compatriotes qui
faisait les thèses qui est tous et tous
ces contes où nos compatriotes ont été
testés à deux reprises à leur arrivée et
une semaine après donc il ya eu cette
volonté de les accueillir au mieux est
de prendre en charge des premiers cas et
les clusters avec des moyens importants
et c'était sait comment delà du 30
janvier de d'équipements de protection
individuelle emparée de tout à l'heure
elle est sûre blues et surchaussures
l'élégant et les lunettes
et puis de t'être 4 2 capable de
répondre aux besoins des soignants qui a
fait que mes deux commandes du 30
janvier et du 8 février
c'était des masques ffp2 justement pour
pour qu'on puisse comprendre puisse
répondre aux enjeux soignants il ya eu
aussi des masques pédiatrique qui ont pu
servir vous le savez dans les écoles
récemment donc il ya aussi cette
capacité de d'avoir des masques
pédiatrique et il ya effectivement cette
réponse d'état que vous avez que vous
avez souligné qu'ils aient cette réponse
à une crise totalement inédite puisque
nous avons mis en place face justement à
ces enjeux de ce top dormance elle est
en fait un top qui finalement ne bouge
pas il ya peu de peu d'arrivées peu de
sorties et parfois des destructions et
parfois des commandes
nous avions là à répondre à une crise
totalement inédite et avoir rapidement
des quantités très importantes de
masques ce d'autant qu'on observait
cette consommation totalement inédite en
particulier par les professionnels de
santé du fait de l'épidémie
donc c'est un pilotage que nous avons
mis en place avec évidemment le
ministère santé publique france et la
direction de crise et nous avons
beaucoup échangé avec les acteurs de
terrain et c'est pour ça que c'est
important de le rappeler
puisqu'il y avait plusieurs filières il
y avait une filière d'accès aux
établissements de santé
là nous avons beaucoup de télésanté
évidemment où il y avait aucune raison
de faire des différences entre les
établissements de santé nous étions
quand même assez attentif aussi au fait
que la situation en france était
hétérogène
vous savez qu'il ya des différences
entre les pays européens dans la
circulation du virus mais il ya aussi
des différences entre les départements
français en terme de circulation du
virus avait des goûts des gradients très
important qu'on ne s'explique pas
mais c'est important de le dire et donc
nous avons voulu répondre en urgence la
nuit aux départements les plus touchés
donc on a fait des livraisons
extrêmement urgente pour les hôpitaux
qui étaient en première ligne du grand
test des routes de france par exemple et
nous avons décidé que nous aurions un
point d'entrée initial qui serait le
j'ai acheté le groupe hospitalier de
territoire puisque c'est celui qui est
le plus connecté avec son territoire et
qui permet aussi de distribuer aux ehpad
donc ça permettait d' que vraiment un
échelon territorial ya la distribution
deuxième deuxième enjeu la distribution
depuis santé publique france depuis les
entrepôts tenté blick france vers les
professionnels de santé
quand on avait besoin évidemment
rapidement avec les demandes du ministre
de déstocker ces masques et là il a été
décidé de passer par les grossistes
répartiteurs puis par les officines face
à une crise aussi inédite aussi massive
aussi mondial avec l'arrêt de la
production du plus gros producteurs qui
était la chine il a fallu mettre en
place une chaîne totalement dédié pour
que ce pont aérien se met en place et
plusieurs avions par semaine et des
quantités massives pour répondre et pour
finalement délivré déjà 770 millions de
masse il y à aussi et on n'a pas
suffisamment dit et je l'avais beaucoup
demandé par ailleurs avant la
mobilisation des producteurs français de
masques ffp2 et de masques chirurgicaux
parce qu'il nous avons plusieurs
producteurs français qui ont accepté de
tripler leur capacité de travailler jour
et nuit sur la femme fabrication de
masques sanitaires dont nous avons cette
augmentation de production de masques
sur le territoire national en fait nous
avions trois sources un peu compliqué
mais il y avait le stock stratégique
d'état la production nationale de
masques et l'importation massive de
masques en particulier depuis la chine
pour répondre à deux circuits répondre
aux besoins des professionnels de santé
en établissement répondre aux besoins
des professionnels de santé en ville
et puis on a aussi répondu et c'était
pas forcément évident parce que c'était
pas aussi simple que ça à des
professionnels qui se portaient auprès
de personnes fragiles donc de qui
intervenait notamment à domicile
j'étais dans le grand est la première
région impacté et les alertes de
médecins généralistes de terrain dès le
mois de février
anvers l' agence régionale de santé
grand test n'ont eu aucun écho donc
est-ce que celle agences régionales de
santé qui n'a pas fait son travail de
remonter ou est-ce que c'est au niveau
national qu on n'a pas écouté entendu
l'agencé régionale de santé les médecins
hospitaliers ont eu quelques protections
avec retard les médecins libéraux ont
payé un très lourd tribut cinq fois plus
de décès qu'à l'hôpital
puisqu'ils n'ont été protégé que
extrêmement tardivement en première
ligne les médecins généralistes à partir
des de la promulgation des décrets des
25 et 26 mars n'ont plus accès aux
traitements on ne pouvait vous avez cité
l'hydroxyde chloroquine on ne pouvait
utiliser cette molécule notamment qu'à
partir du moment où les patients étaient
en état grave à l'hôpital
donc là nous avions déjà perdu beaucoup
de temps et les premières études avaient
déjà démontré que cette hydroxy
chloroquine ne servait plus à rien donc
comment expliquer monsieur salomon que
la france soit quasi championne du monde
de la létalité des décisions trop
souvent émotionnel rapides ont été
prises notamment suite à la parution de
l'étude du land 7
comment expliquer en effet cette
attitude n'eût-il pas fallu être plus
modéré plus réfléchie quel était
l'intérêt de votre apparition
quotidiennement à 19 heures etait-ce
pour terroriser les français ou pour les
infantiliser sur le grand est
c'est une particularité de cette
épidémie s'est drôlement le territoire
qui a été le plus touché et ce n'est
évidemment pas lié aux médecins du grand
test ou aux patients du grand test
on ne comprend pas aujourd'hui c'est
très différent d'ailleurs d'une pandémie
grippale pourquoi ce virus frappent à
certains endroits et pas à d'autres
et je crois que les professionnels de
santé du grand test ont été remarquables
donc c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
quand même dire
les alertes ont été prises nous avons
mis en place un dispositif totalement
exceptionnel de renfort de réserve
sanitaire
le dizaines de réservistes et notamment
d'aide-soignante d'infirmières de
l'animateur qui sont montés au créneau
des hôpitaux nous avons envoyé un
hôpital militaire à mulhouse nous avons
envoyé des respirateurs nous avons
évacué plus de 300 patients des hôpitaux
en interrégional en intra régional donc
il ya eu une énorme solidarité nationale
pour pour le grand test
après je crois qu'il n'y a pas de guerre
entre les médecins libéraux et médecins
hospitaliers surtout dans le grand est
où ils ont été tous au front vraiment je
jugeais des histoires des médecins
généralistes qui avaient fermé leur
cabinet qui ont été prendre des gardes
aux urgences j'ai des médecins
hospitaliers qui se sont occupés de
d'ehpad où il y avait plus de médecins
traitants enfin je crois qu'il ya eu
comme souvent dans le grand est
d'ailleurs une magnifique fraternité de
magnifiques solidarité des soignants sur
ce que vous dites en termes de
traitement
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure sur l'île
roxy chloroquine on a tout fait pour que
en passant par les cppa les comités de
protection des personnes l agence
nationale secrètes les médicaments
toutes les hypothèses de traitement soit
immédiatement traités et qu'on puisse
offrir l'accès aux traitements et c'est
le sait le cadre du décret à toutes les
personnes qui voulaient inscrire les
patients dans un protocole de suivi et
on a fait en sorte avec le ministre que
l'on puisse faire des protocoles de
prise en charge prophylactique des
protocoles de prise en charge en ville
justement pour que les médecins
généralistes puissent inclure
l'impatient donc on a été très attentif
on a vous savez saisi le haut conseil de
santé publique le conseil scientifique
s'est mobilisé aussi de l'agencé saba
sécurité du médicament et le ministre a
écrit hollande 7 dont je crois que naît
il a été très attentif à ce qui s'est
passé sur la polémique hydroxyque laurie
qui n'est malheureusement c'est ça qui
est terrible c'est que dans un domaine
où il ya tant d'incertitudes
scientifiques ya toujours des débats
scientifiques et parfois des querelles
qui sont peut-être très difficile à
entendre pour nos concitoyens
ensuite sur mon rôle peu importe ma
personne
mon rôle de communication il a été
décidé par la ministre que nous devions
être dans la transparence et l'humidité
dans la transparence sur ce qu'on savait
et donc on devait tous les jours dire ce
que l'on savait et quel était l'état de
la situation et de la même forme de la
même façon avoir beaucoup d'humilité et
dire qu'on ne savait pas beaucoup de
choses
et je crois que sur votre constat que la
france est parmi les pays les plus
touchés
c'est effectivement vrai mais personne
ne sait expliquer aujourd'hui la crise
est loin d'être terminée nous sommes
encore à la tâche le l'inde est
actuellement massivement touchée
l'afrique du sud
pékin referme ses écoles donc voilà je
pense qu'il faut qu'on soit très modeste
tous ensemble sur ce qui se passe et
pourquoi certaines personnes certains
pays sont plus touchés que d'autres je
suis frappé de voir que le grand ouest
la bretagne normandie lunven aquitaine
sont beaucoup moins touchés que le grand
test que les hauts de france que conil
de france en allemagne c'est exactement
pareil la bavière est beaucoup plus
touchée que la plupart des autres länder
vous prenez le sud de l'italie qui est
plutôt plus pauvre que le nord il est
beaucoup moins touchés donc je crois que
voilà il faut qu'on soit capable de
faire le point lorsqu'on aura toutes les
données mais je crois qu'en tout cas si
malheureusement nous avons cette
mortalité effroyable et cette pénalité
importante
ce n'est certainement pas en raison
d'une quelconque carence médical ou d'un
déficit de prise en charge parce que
vraiment les médecins du grand test en
particulier donc certain que je connais
bien ont été remarquables ce manque de
tests a suscité l'inquiétude chez nombre
de nos concitoyens car un parcours de
soin commence par un diagnostic et seuls
10 h militaire année infections à
marseille a pu testé massivement les
patients se présentant à ses portes
réalisant jusqu'à au quart des tests
quotidiens du pays alors monsieur le
directeur général pouvez vous nous
expliquer les bases scientifiques et
épidémiologiques sur lesquels vous avez
déclaré que les tests de diagnostic
kovy 19 n'avait pas beaucoup d'intérêt
et pouvez-vous en août nous expliquer
pourquoi le ministère a attendu le 5
avril pour autoriser les laboratoires ap
à réaliser des diagnostics par pcr comme
les laboratoires de recherche et les
laboratoires vétérinaires à participer à
l'effort national de dépistage somme a
maintenant huit millions de tests qu'il
ya eu
vous savez du 17 mars au 11 mai une
période de confinement importante où
effectivement l'accès aux tests a été
plus compliqué et puis il ya eu cette
augmentation très forte de capacités de
test puisque nous sommes aujourd'hui à
un capacitaire de cent mille tests par
jour
qui n'est pas d'ailleurs utilisé donc
nous avons cette capacité de tester nous
avons poussé aujourd'hui la doctrine qui
est de tester toutes les personnes
positives
évidemment tous leurs contacts et plus
largement les clusters et les
populations fragiles donc j'ai donné
déjà tout à l'heure le début de la
chronologie mais je peux la continue
pour vous parce que c'est important
le 21 février il y avait vingt
laboratoires qui était capable de faire
le test
et à l'époque en face d'eux donc nous
avions quelques cas en france
nous faisions entre 2000 et 2500 thèse
par jour c'est vous donner quand même
l'évolution de notre de notre capacité
de laboratoire et je pense que les les
laboratoires français en fait un énorme
effort parce que c'est un nouveau test
parce qu'il faut de l'équipement parce
qu'il faut un personnel dédié pour
passer de 2000 tests par jour a
aujourd'hui une capacité de 200 mille
tonnes par jour donc nous avons dès le
26 février un courrier du dgs qui
demande officiellement au centre
national de référence de déployer ce
test à l'ensemble des hôpitaux de second
niveau
nous avons par ailleurs évalué très vite
à la demande des laboratoires les kits
commerciaux puisque ça a été fait dès la
première semaine de mars nous avons
d'ailleurs demandé au haut conseil qui a
publié son avis le 5 mars de donner la
conduite à tenir sur les tests nous
avons saisi la haute autorité de santé
qui le 6 mars a fait état là aussi deux
des recommandations à suivre pour la
détection du génome du coronavirus des
tests rt pcr ont été inscrits à la
nomenclature dès le 7 mars
et c'est le 7 mars qu'il y avait déjà 43
laboratoire capable de faire le test et
nous avons ensuite augmenter dès mi mars
à 5 me taise par jour donc nous avions
ces cinq cent mille tests pendant la
période de confinement avec les
difficultés que vous pouvez imaginer
pour les tests que nous avions prioriser
pour les ehpad je vous rappelle qu'à
l'époque le ministre a demandé à ce que
les épate retester en priorité c'était
tout à fait cohérent avec la protection
de ces personnes les plus fragiles et
puis par ailleurs des le déconfinement
plus d'1 2 million de tests réalisés je
pense qu'il faut qu'on encore encourager
la réalisation de ces tests puisque
effectivement avec ces tests sont
arrivés aussi des tests sérologiques et
qu'avec un tests virologiques un test
sérologique ça peut aider le médecin
soit reconstitué une histoire médicale
soit
à un statut et notamment sur le statut
sérologique des soignants et c'est
important évidemment pour les soignants
de savoir s'ils ont été ou non exposés
donc à chaque fois des avis du haut
conseil des avis de la haute autorité de
santé il ya eu même un avis du conseil
scientifique sur le dépistage
sérologique et donc notre objectif est
vraiment aujourd'hui de tester
évidemment les professionnels de santé
les résidents en ehpad à chaque fois que
c'est nécessaire et s'il le faut
plusieurs fois par ehpad s'il ya des
foyers les fous les populations qui vit
dans des lieux très confiné en
particulier les détenus ce qui vit dans
des structures collectives d'hébergement
d'urgence
et puis les opérateurs d'importance
vitale donc nous avons en permanence
élargi notre servent pour que toutes les
personnes qui ont une indication de
tests puissent la voix et aujourd'hui
nous avons une stratégie encore plus
large qui est de tester autour des
clusters que d'aller vers les
populations les plus défavorisées et que
d'aller faire des campagnes
systématiques de dépistage des lieux à
risque donc le nombre de tests cidep
c'est un système d'information pour le
diagnostic de laboratoire et disponible
sur le site de santé publique france
vous avez ce nombre de tests fournis de
façon hebdomadaire par santé publique
france et l'objectif c'est qu'il y ait
la plus grande transparence puisque
c'est le système système national de
suivi des tests biologiques et les tests
virologiques pour qu'on puisse justement
suivre c'est indispensable de
progression je reviendrai sur votre note
qui a été fortement évoqué du 5
septembre 2016 que vous adressiez à
emmanuel macron où vous souligner la
nécessité d'une révision en profondeur
de la réponse nationale face au risque
majeur de catastrophe
votre constat était alors sans appel la
france n'est pas prête
vous avez pris vos fonctions en janvier
2018 quelles ont été les actions que
vous avez conduit pour pallier cette
situation notamment en termes de moyens
matériels les réserves étatique abritait
très précisément 714 millions de masques
chirurgicaux
parmi ceux-ci 616 millions datant pour
l'essentiel de 2005 et 2006 sans date de
péremption
les 98 millions restants ayant été
acquis entre 2014 et 2016
or en mars 2020 il ne restait plus
malheureusement qu'un stock de 117
millions
les 80 18 millions acquis entre 2014 et
19 millions qui ont échappé à la
destruction en moins de trois ans les
stocks ont été divisés par six pourquoi
la quasi totalité des 6 116 millions de
masques chirurgicaux ont ainsi étaient
détruits entre 2017 et 2019 alors qu'il
ne portait pas de date de péremption que
nos stocks étaient très en deçà de nos
besoins
je vous ai entendu dire qu'effectivement
il était défectueux j'aimerais que vous
me confirment y est que selon mes
sources
la direction générale de l'armement et
l' agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament et des produits de santé ont
été saisis dans l'urgence par le
ministère de la santé afin d'évaluer la
fiabilité des millions de masques
épargné par la sidération et il se
serait avéré que les tests sont revenus
face de façon favorable permettant ainsi
l'utilisation de ce qui n'avait pas été
incinéré par ailleurs au regard de la
destruction massive des 616 millions de
masques comment expliquez-vous que
seulement 100 millions et été
recommandée puisque vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure en 2019 et plus j'ai
juste un petit point concernant les
pharmaciens puisque je suis pharmacien
et nous avons effectivement été
mobilisés pour la distribution des
masques
je pense que les 22000 officines
effectivement répartis sur l'ensemble du
territoire national aurait pu distribuer
de façon efficace les masques mais nous
avons été confrontés à des ordres et
contre ordres permanents
nous avons été victime de critiques
voire d' insulte puisque nous avions des
listes de professionnels approvisionnés
avec un nombre dédié de masse qui ne
correspondait pas du tout à leurs
besoins et comment expliquer par
ailleurs que certains professionnels ne
figurait pas sur les listes
je pense par exemple au kinésithérapeute
au service d'aidé à domicile ou au ciad
comment expliquez vous aussi que nous
étions interdit de vendre des masques
même à des personnes très vulnérables
alors que un grand nombre d'entre nous
en posséder bien adaptés nono
outil de réponse aux menaces majeures
qui avaient été identifiées en
particulier à la déclinaison et aux
exercices nécessaire dans l'ensemble des
régions sur les différents risques dans
le cadre du plan enr san
il y a aussi le labo ration est là et la
rédaction du guide spécifique situation
sanitaire exceptionnel
et puis il ya ce que vous avez décrit
effectivement sur la réponse en terme de
moyens à l'audit demandé par la dgs sa
santé publique france donc sur l'essai
de 154 millions de 2018 il ya bien eu
and audit par un expert indépendant
compétent pour juger d'un cap et de la
qualité des tests départ non des masques
sur ces masques 200 plus de 230 millions
ont été détruits au vu de ces analyses
mais il ya eu plus de 360 millions de
masques n'ont détruit aussi et qui ont
été effectivement vous avez parfaitement
bien dit expertise et en 2020 et
requalifier en masque non sanitaire
puisque même 142 millions ont déjà été
délivrés donc effectivement vous avez
raison il ya bien eu une demande
d'expertisé d'urgence de la dg réduire
ensuite sur le rôle difficile des
officines je le conçois nous avions
estimé avec le conseil national de
l'ordre des pharmaciens que c'était une
réponse optimale en termes de proximité
de connaissance du delà du responsable
de la responsable d'officine au en
verser ses collègues professionnels de
santé et nous avons adapté en permanence
les flux pas forcément de façon évidente
je le conçois totalement et avec des
tensions que je connais bien aussi dans
certaines officines du fait de la
difficulté ressentie par certains
professionnels pour avoir accès aux eaux
masque est par ailleurs pour pour
répondre à différents professionnels qui
n'avaient pas le même exercice vous avez
parfaitement citer les kinés par exemple
mais aussi des intervenants à domicile
et donc nous avons en permanence tenter
de corriger le tir en fonction des des
remontées de terrain que vous ne faisiez
souhaité revenir sur les prusse ayant
rapporté la loi giro en 2007 ayant
construit l'eprus puis lors de la
commission denquête avec mon collègue
jean-christophe lagarde deux achats et
lun nous avons enquêté sur les prusse et
nous avons constaté que ces sept
établissements étaient en ordre de
mobilisation que c'était véritable
bouclier sanitaire contre les pandémies
et que tout était prêt
donc quand on parle de deux plans près
cela était fait donc en 2011
il y avait six le directeur de l'épreuve
de l'époque thierry coudert confirme 600
millions de masques ffp2 un milliard de
masques chirurgicaux et quelques miliers
de respirateurs donc j'ai toujours pas
quels ont été achetés par l'ugap l'ordre
de soit 6,6 millions d'euros on avait un
peu plus de 2000 sur les sources 6000
proposé qui devait ouvrir six mille lits
de réanimation en supplément des 5000
existants
donc tout était prêt mais en 2013 où
cela a été dit une nouvelle doctrine
vient séparer les stocks entre les
stocks tactique et les stops traque
stratégique donc les stocks stratégiques
c'est ce d'état et les stocks tactique à
devait être acheté par les employeurs
les hôpitaux etc ça sortait de l'état
mois pour moi c'est le début de la
décroissance et c'est le début monsieur
le directeur du désarmement de l'eprus
et qui s'est accentué bien entendu
lorsqu'on l'a fusionner dans santé
publique france alors il ya des
obligations au niveau de l'eprus des
obligations jeudi rappelle c'est par
convention c'est d'alerter le ministre
sur les besoins de renouvellement des
produits un an avant la date de
préemption et cdh adressée au directeur
général de la santé tous les documents
nécessaires au renouvellement un an à 1
davance de la date de préhension
alors ma question est simple est-ce
qu'il ya pas eu des difficultés de
gestion dans l'épreuve que vous l'ayez
pas été avertis ou qui vous ait des
regrets de ne pas l'avoir constaté et
d'avoir pu anticiper parce que lorsqu'on
a des commandes qu'en 2018 200 millions
alors que l'état les l'état
catastrophique en 2017 il ya plus d'un
an avant constate qu' il ya des dates de
péremption
donc chapeau j'ai l'impression qui a
manifestement un défaut de gestion dans
l'organisation de cette période entre
2011 et 2020 2011
évolution vous l'avez vous l'avez
souligné de la doctrine à la fois sur
des stocks stratégiques les stops
tactique la responsabilité de
l'employeur ça c'est une évolution
importante sur le aussi d'utiliser
sondés des masques ffp2 la création de
santé publique france je pense que vous
avez un témoin extraordinaire demain qui
est le les préfigurateurs et le
directeur général du cld de santé blick
france donc je pense que il vous donnera
son opinion mais mais objectivement il y
avait une certaine cohérence en tout cas
dans ce que j'ai deux je reprends des
débats à ce que l'eprus puisse rejoindre
un établissement tel que tels que santé
publique france en termes de
surveillance populationnelle de réaction
face à un événement de santé donc je
rappelle que l'eprus d'ailleurs n'a pas
que cette logique de réserve mais aussi
le a déjà le stock mais a aussi la
réserve sanitaire qui est quelque chose
qui fonctionne bien avec des
professionnels volontaires qui souvent
se projette à distance et ont fait des
merveilles dans des départements
voilà enfin et il ya des points positifs
et peut-être des points à revoir c'est
évident moi ce que je ce que je retiens
dans votre intervention si vous le
permettez c'est qu'effectivement il y à
cet enjeu des masses
il ya aussi d'autres d'équipements qui
sont dans les stocks stratégiques et qui
nécessite effectivement que l'on s'y
penche et des équipements qui n'y
figurent pas et puis il ya eu d'autres
évolutions dans les demandes
je pense par exemple à l'évolution sur
les antidotes tout sur les antiviraux
sur la commande de vaccins est donc là
aussi ça fait partie de la réflexion
générale qu'on doit avoir sur quel doit
être le stock stratégique de l'état de
quoi il doit être constitué que les sons
son volume est calé en particulier quels
sont les éléments manquants au vu de
cette crise qui pourrait être ajoutée
aux stocks stratégiques
mais trois questions la mise en
quarantaine se généralise à wuhan en
chine à partir du 24 janvier nous y
avons un consulte un consul qui a dû
vous alerter de plus nous avons appris
par la presse que notre ambassadeur à
pékin a alerté sans doute à plusieurs
reprises le gouvernement 300 français
ont été rapatriés cette époque en
janvier avez vous reçu ces alertes
sous quelle forme et comment les avez
vous traitez seconde question le 21
février l'impérial collège de londres
explique que les deux tiers des français
des chinois touché et qui se déplace à
l'étranger ne sont pas détectés l'italie
prend les devants confine
à partir du 23 février le président
macron annonce lui seulement le
confinement de 16 mars la france a pris
beaucoup de retard
et entre temps beaucoup de personnes
sont contaminées dont concitoyens
panique ne dispose d'aucune protection
le 26 février vous déclariez pourtant
que santé publique france dispose de
stocks stratégiques importants de
masques chirurgicaux et que vous n'avez
pas d'inquiétude sur ce plan vous
rajoutiez qu'il n'y avait pas de pénurie
a redouté et que ce n'était pas un sujet
cependant mi mars via mi avril
rares sont les personnes pour le grand
public à pouvoir s'en procurer
y compris par mille personnes le
personnel médical le 29 février vous
déclariez que le masque n'était pas la
bonne réponse pour le grand public
thoniers vous ces propos parce que vous
saviez que nous n'avions pas
suffisamment de masques
dernière question vous aviez pendant la
campagne présidentielle envoyé note au
futur président pour l'alerter en
expliquant que la france n'était pas
prête à la gestion des grandes
catastrophes
qu'avez vous entrepris depuis pour y
remédier sur l' alerte chinoise comme je
voulais dit elle a été
internationalement répercuter fin
décembre et reprise ensuite par l' oms
et puis avec d'identification du virus
au début du mois de janvier donc sur de
l'information qui étaient publics et que
nous avons d'emblée échangé avec que
l'om est bien sûr mais avec aussi le
site ici européen au début janvier ça a
permis d'ailleurs que nous envoyons une
alerte aux ars et aux établissements de
santé dès le 10 et le 14 janvier et
qu'on nous parlions de ce sujet dès le 8
donc une information qui était qui
étaient partagés évidemment avec que les
professionnels de santé sur les
mouvements de populations
c'est toujours un sujet et c'est très
compliqué puisque aujourd'hui on a
appris et on ne savait pas à l'époque
que il peut y avoir des personnes
asymptomatiques avant les symptômes qui
peut même y avoir des personnes
asymptomatiques sans symptôme qui est là
qui leur est donc la stratégie de
dépistage de d'éventuels porter et
complexes vous parlez de l'italie
malheureusement l'italie est très
fortement touchée comme nous
l'impact du confinement il a été évalué
par une équipe de modélisateurs de nîmes
banal college ça a été publiée quelques
jours comme étant extrêmement positif en
terme de nombre de vies sauvées
donc le confinement a quand même permis
de sauver beaucoup de vies en france et
c'est important de le dire parce que les
françaises et les français ont fait
d'énormes efforts sur la pénurie nous
avons toujours dit ce que nous savions
et ce que nous ne savions pas donc nous
avons été dans la transparence et les
français ont été informés chaque jour de
la situation quant à quant aux masques
je vous ai déjà un petit peu dit comment
nous raisonnions pas sur la priorité aux
soignants sur le le port du masque pour
les malades et sur le la discussion
qu'il y avait autour de l'aérosol
éventuel ou la transmission du virus
autrement que par des gouttelettes et
donc nous avons toujours suivi les
experts les recommandations
internationales fait état de ce que nous
savions où disent que nous ne savions
pas nous avons agi évidemment dans les
commandes ensuite massives de masques au
fur et à mesure que les besoins s'en
faisait sentir et l' oms a encore eu un
débat début juin sur la recommandation
éventuelle de du port du masque en
espace public en insistant comme nous le
faisons d'ailleurs sur le fait qu'il
était plutôt raisonnable de le proposer
dans les espaces clos et lorsque les
mesures barrière notamment la distance
d'un mètre ne pouvait pas être respectée
dans les textes réglementaires relatifs
aux restrictions de prescriptions
notamment paul hydro libre auxi
chloroquine ont fait référence à un avis
du haut conseil de la santé publique du
24 mars 2020 et on ne vise pas l'agencé
nationale de sécurité du médicament
pourquoi est-ce que sur l'hydroxyde
chloroquine ce n'est pas la haine sm qui
a plutôt orienté l'édition
gouvernementale la deuxième question
pose sur le fait que vous avez expliqué
votre rôle
sur la réorientation de la stratégie en
parlant du plan horse and reb qui vise
notamment donc à s'adapter au risque
biologique mais qui a succédé à un plan
qui s'appelait le plan hors scène enfin
il y avait quelque chose en tout cas sur
l'épidémie et la pandémie c'est le plan
ours and heavy pas qu est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer entrées vip
acquerrait ben ce que vous avez rajouté
parce que en le parcourant je n'ai rien
trouvé dans heavy pas que sur les
masques et sur rêve j'ai trouvé
effectivement quelques éléments sur les
stocks de masques ffp2 pour les
établissements vous étiez conseiller à
la sécurité sanitaire faut-il comprendre
que les masques n'apparaissait pas dans
ses plans comme un pan de la sécurité
sanitaire
la troisième question porte sur la
différence du port du masque contre le
grand public et les soignants pourquoi
n'at-on pas appliquer un principe de
précaution
il ya une étude du lancet de 2003 qui
montre que les masses qui semble
essentiel pour la protection bien plus
que les blues les gants et les
désinfectants pourquoi est-ce que du
coup on n'a pas inclus je dirais ceci
comme élément de protection
enfin j'ai deux questions plus précises
vous avez commandé un million de masques
le 30 janvier 28.5 le 7 février
si j'ai si je me rappelle bien de vos
chiffres c'est à dire en moins d'une
semaine quand même je dirais une
commande beaucoup plus importante
il se trouve dans la même semaine le ms
a considéré le nouveau coronavirus comme
un risque de santé publique mondial et
pour la première fois on a parlé des
patients asymptomatiques
est-ce que c'est l'apparition de
patients asymptomatiques a justifié
l'augmentation de la commande de masques
et pourquoi est ce que le 19 février
alors que vous saviez qu'il y avait peu
de masque on en a donné à la chine par
un pont aérien
enfin dernière question en république
tchèque le 19 mars en slovaquie en
slovénie en autriche le 30 masques on a
recommandé le port du masque pour le
grand public
vous nous avez expliqué que l' oms ne le
recommanderais pas comment
expliquez-vous que d'autres pays
européens et fait ce choix et vous même
vous avez expliqué le 22 février que le
port du masque n'était pas la solution
pour le grand public
et le 22 avril vous avez dit j'ai
toujours plaidé pour l'accès aux masques
grand public ce qui me semble être une
contradiction plus que vous êtes
infectiologues et épidémiologiques quel
est votre avis à vous sur le port du
masque grand public par rapport aux
risques épidémiques
merci alors sur la vie donc si
chloroquine juste pour vous rassurer
évidemment les recommandations du haut
conseil sont plutôt des recommandations
de pratique
par contre là nsn a toujours son rôle
d'évaluation du médicament l2 fait
d'ailleurs puisque vous avez vu qu'il y
avait beaucoup de publications soient
hydroxy chloroquine et un particulier de
pharmacovigilance tant que ça se fait
vraiment de façon simultanée
vous avez bien noté effectivement
l'évolution du plan et pis vague vers le
plan rêves leurs épis vako juste pour
préciser c'était les épidémies et
l'urgence vaccinale ils nous avaient
permis n'est paru peut-être une source
de confusion qu'on mélange la gestion
d'une épidémie est une campagne
vaccinale parce que d'ailleurs on le
voit aujourd'hui on peut avoir une
épidémie sans campagne vaccinale est
donc c'était pour ça qu'on voulait
préciser les choses en particulier
déroulé pour les soignants je pense que
c'est ça l'important du plan rêve c'est
pour les infirmières pour les
aides-soignants comment on fait pour
accueillir un patient à risque
un patient avec des boules à un patient
avec eux avec un courant navires us dès
l'arrivée à l'hôpital et c'est un peu
cette procédure très précise qui a été
précisé vous avez fait une note en 2017
emmanuel macron et vous avez dit lorsque
j'ai été nommé voilà ce que j'ai apporté
j'ai apporté le plan en ça ne règle donc
en quoi est ce qu'il ya une plus value
par rapport à ce qui était préalablement
puisque c'est la base de votre
argumentation
alors justement pour éviter de mélanger
on va dire du banal épidémie classique
c'est à dire comment gères à foyers
épidémiques dans une danse dans une
collectivité gastro entérite de la
rougeole voilà c'est le plan c'était le
plan épi qui étaient mélangés avec un
plan de vaccination massive comme on a
pu en connaître avec des nécessité de
s'organiser face à une machination
massive avec une autre approche du
risque qui nous paraissait plus fine et
plus déroulé concrètement par rapport
aux soignants était justement la gestion
du risque épidémique biologique c'est à
dire soit une réponse à un cas
individuel à haut risque et c'était
l'exemple des mollahs
où il fallait déroulé des moyens de
protection très important et je vous
rappelle qu'à ce moment là on est plus
sûr du masque demande et bien sûr des
équipements complets de protection c'est
pas la même dotation et c'est pas la
même réponse est complice déroulé
l'alerté précoce face à une émergence
d'où la prise en charge qui a été
d'ailleurs très satisfaisante au début
et qu'on a mise en place et qui a été
très fonctionnelle des premiers cas qui
ont été parfaitement diagnostiqué dans
les établissements de santé de référence
avec le lien infectiologues et
épidémiologistes biologiste réanimateurs
ccsa le l'avancé qui est la chaîne de
prise en charge d'un patient à risque
épidémique biologique élevé dans un
établissement santé de référence qui est
équipé qu'il ya une dotation qui a
délaissé des infirmières des aides
soignantes formés qui ont des des
structures des cadres de santé de
référence qui ont des exercices
réguliers qui ont des dotations
spécifiques et zetes à l'intérêt d'avoir
nos établissements de santé de référence
sur la distinction entre grand public et
soignants vous citez de l'en-tête de
2003 moi je vous ai cité le lent de
cette 2020 ce qui est très compliqué
c'est qu'en fait à chaque fois qu'ils
les études sur les masques et je partage
avec vous ce projet pas de d'opinion
pour ou contre simplement je dis que
c'est compliqué à mettre en évidence
on a souvent d'autres mesures barrières
associés et en particulier à un effet
majeur que vous pouvez bien imaginer
quel effet distance donc comme souvent
quand les gens mettre des masques ou
mettre des barrières ou mettre des
lunettes il ya aussi l'effet distance et
que la plupart des études montrent que
l'effet distance est supérieur à tout le
reste
et puis il y a une difficulté que qui me
kim qui est importante à signaler c'est
que le port du masque semble efficace
dans ses études c'est pas une position
personnelle quand beaucoup de gens le
porte massivement et quand ils le
portent tout le temps ce qui est aussi
une difficulté ça veut dire qu'il faut
prendre l'habitude de le porter
massivement c'est à dire quasiment tout
le monde de portes et le port tout le
temps et vous savez que là aussi c'est
difficile par rapport à un port
important
et puis par ailleurs la notion de
patients asymptomatiques est
effectivement apparu mais a été
régulièrement
discuter et puis il ya eu ce que vous
décrivez c'est à dire cette demande
progressive et cette évolution de des
expertises je cite simplement puisque
vous m'en parler les différents experts
il n'y a pas d'indication dans la vidéo
conseil de l'avs d'avril de mai 19 n'y a
pas de recommandations oms en 2019 n'y a
pas de port de masques d'après les
sociétés savantes société française
d'hygiène hospitalière et société de
pathologie infectieuse dans la vie du 4
mars 2020 pas de recommandations n'ont
plus de port du masque au 14 mars 2009
un avis du haut conseil
pas de recommandations sur les avis du
conseil scientifique priorité doit être
donnée aux personnels de santé de la vie
de l'académie de médecine et puis un
débat scientifique qui s'ouvre vous avez
raison de le souligner fin mars début
avril avec une discussion nous savez si
d'ici américain au sein de la vie de l'
oms et un avis très prudent décide ici
européen qui dit effectivement qu'on
peut le tester en même temps que les
états unis disaient que c'était que par
dont le royaume-uni disait que c'était
non recommandé d'envoyer que on a on a
tenu compte de cette de ce débat
scientifique de ces différentes
recommandations internationales qui
évolue au fil du temps et nous avons eu
la chance d'avoir ce masque grand public
qui a été créée en france en tissu
lavable réutilisables et que les
français se sont appropriés et je trouve
que c'est une très bonne chose que les
français se soit approprié ce masque
grand public qui est réutilisable et qui
est une production française
donc s'il y a attiré peut-être une leçon
de ses débuts ce début de crise de sept
premiers mois
c'est que si les français s'emparent de
ce nouveaux gestes barrières permis se
sont emparés il ya quelques années les
solutions hydroalcooliques on aura
probablement progresser dans les mesures
barrières
vous avez donné l' alerte me semble-t-il
vous l'avez dit confirmé aujourd'hui le
10 janvier le 21 janvier la ministre de
la santé disait que les risques de
propagation de l'épidémie était faible
onze jours après que vous ayez donné l'
alerte vous avez donné l' alerte le 10
janvier la fermeture aux visites dans
les ehpad date du 11 mars
la distribution des masques dans les
ehpad le 22 mars la liaison directe
entre les ehpad et le samu le 23 mars et
le 30 mars le conseil scientifique
prioriser résident dans leur politique
de test
sur santé publique france vous avez
donné l' alerte le 10 janvier la saisine
de santé publique france par les
autorités ministérielles date du 30
janvier
donc la question que je me pose c'est
est ce que vous étiez écoutez monsieur
le directeur général nous avons
effectivement mobilisés les agences
régionales de santé et les
établissements de santé très tôt nous
avons essayé d'informations qui étaient
publics d'ailleurs mais que nous avons
regardé avec beaucoup d'attention une
vigilance la réunion de sécurité
sanitaire qui rassemble l'ensemble des
acteurs de sécurité sanitaire en france
du 8 janvier a abordé ce point donc on a
vraiment fait très attention à notre
évaluation du risque
après vous citez agnès buzyn vous
reprenez les avis de l'om est cédé à vis
du site d'ici européen de cette époque
et je pense qu'ils sont encore en ligne
ou en tout cas elles sont disponibles
ils disaient tous que le risque
d'importation du virus vers l'europe
étaient extrêmement faibles
tout le monde disait sa ou ses traits
chinois vous reprenez la presse c'était
une évaluation assez générale même si
effectivement comme je le disais assez
souvent dans mes points de presse c'est
pas le virus qui circule c'est l'homme
donc il faut il faut être attentif à
notre capacité maintenant de d'affronter
un tout petit village planétaire
donc bon probablement attention contexte
sur sur les ehpad parce que c'est un
point important c'est un sujet
extrêmement sensible
nous on en a discuté avec les
fédérations on en a discuté avec les
soignants même avec des psychologues
c'était très compliqué même deux pour
eux parce que ils nous disent bien que
chaque hiver quand il ya des
bronchiolites quand il ya des grilles
pointait les épidémies fermer une ehpad
fermée aux visites est une est un
déchirement pour les résidents qui n'ont
que ça dans la journée que d'avoir un
proche qui vient donc il était quand
même 13 ans 13 dans là dedans dans l'ain
dans le dans l'interrogation en disant
on sait ce que c'est qu'une épidémie de
grippe vous nous dites qu'il va y avoir
il va y avoir un impact important pour
nos résidents qui sont évidemment des
personnes âgées fragiles mais mais
attention à à prendre la décision au bon
moment laissez nous décider aussi ce
qu'on doit faire comme on doit se
réorganiser
est ce que c'est un confinement
généraliser ce que c'est un confinement
partiel est ce qu'on arrête les visites
des enfants est ce que on
c'est par une crèche qui est à côté
d'eux il ya eu beaucoup de deux
déclinaisons et ça s'est fait vraiment
en discussion très étroite avec les
acteurs du terrain à la fois parce qu'on
a été les rencontrer que le présent
république s'est rendu dans un ehpad
tout au début de mars et que la décision
ensuite de mettre en place le plan bleu
et de leur demander de 2 fermée aux
visites puis de fermer encore plus
sérieusement plus plus de plus durement
j'allais dire en chambre a été une
décision délicate au point qu'on a saisi
le ccn donc que la balance
bénéfice-risque elle est très compliqué
dans sedan sedan ce dans cette démarche
parce qu'on sait très bien qu'on protège
quelqu'un mais aussi que son que
l'impact en collatéral peut être
considérable parce que pas de relation
pas de visite pas de stimulation et des
espoirs qui s'installe voir un syndrome
de glissement donc voila c'était et
c'est une décision vraiment difficile à
prendre
on a eu on a eu cette réorganisation
vous l'avait dit et il faut le souligner
cette réorganisation de passer de 5000 à
10000 places de réanimation avec peu
près en crète 7000 personnes
hospitalisées pour autant on a vu qu'on
avait beaucoup de mal à mobiliser les
personnes non qu'ovide sur de la
pathologie non qu'ovide avec un une
difficulté de route de recours aux soins
avec parfois des retards de diagnostic
est ce qu'on a une évaluation de l'ats
sur morbidité ou surmortalité durant
cette crise
une autre question quel est votre point
de vue actuel sur ce qui se passe en
chine avec la résurgence de quelques de
quelques clusters et troisième point est
ce que l'on doit
réévaluer notre stratégie de prise en
charge des virus type coronavirus avec
d'entrée de jeu intra singh comme le
fait la ceppm actuellement avec des
dépistage massif avec de l'isolément
massif de manière plus généralisée puis
juste une petite précision tout à
l'heure ma collègue se dotait parlait de
de la logistique de livraison des
masques je ne crois pas que nous ayons
aborder la problématique de geodis dans
cette histoire là merci sur votre
hommage à la au doublement des capacités
de réanimation je le partage évidemment
ce que c'est une prouesse humaines et
techniques jeu c'est d'abord de trouver
des équipes qui sont capables de doubler
les effectifs la présence multi
professionnelle métiers disciplinaire
auprès d'un malade de réanimation c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire
évidemment logistique en termes de
pousser les murs à ce que ce qu'on rame
ont fait les soignants c'était tout à
fait magnifique alors là vous vous posez
un sujet très important qui est la
balance qu'il ya eu entre non kovy déco
vide on est montés effectivement à 7
100es 7100 malades kovy d'aupic
mais il y avait encore des lits
disponibles et des malades donc évident
mais par contre effectivement j'ai été
très préoccupé dès le début par par
l'impact de la crise mais peut-être en
terme de ressenti chez des patients
atteints de maladies chroniques qui
n'ont pas osé déranger leurs médecins
traitants se disant qu'il était déjà au
front qui n'ont pas osé aller à
l'hôpital en service de néphrologie
harbulot de pneumo de de suivi est mato
parce qu'ils étaient peut être inquiet
sur la sécurité du parcours et donc on a
très vite dit attention si vous avez une
maladie chronique si vous avez des soins
si vous avez un dépistage de cancers si
vous avez des chimios si vous avez des
soins à faire
faites-les en a même dit on aux parents
de faire vacciner leurs enfants donc il
y avait des soins de santé publique ou
des soins de suivi de pathologies
chroniques était absolument
indispensable
il y a un impact qui est maintenant bien
démontrer et documentée par santé
publique france à la fois sur la baisse
des consultations et sur l'augmentation
de sa tante de pathologie et il ya des
résultats tout assez atypique
il ya des gens qui ont même entre
guillemets améliorer leur état de santé
pendant la crise donc peut-être aussi
parce que le mode de vie était très
différent
pendant la crise qu'ils ont fait
peut-être plus attention à eux ou à leur
traitement tout est possible il ya eu à
la fois
cette évolution favorable et défavorable
ça je parle de l'état clinique
il ya eu aussi vous le savez l'impact
sur la santé mentale et c'est très
important sur la qualité de vie au sein
du dieu de la famille et il ya au sein
du couple ont tout ça doit faire l'objet
d'une évaluation précise c'était
peut-être encore un peu tôt parce que
notamment pour les pathologies
chroniques il faut qu'on sache si ça a
un impact sur les cancers sur les
pathologies neuro cardio vasculaires
mais en tout cas c'est évidemment très
très important et puis il y a eu le boom
et ça c'est peut-être un bénéfice de
cette crise le boom des
téléconsultations les français ont
appris aussi à joindre leur médecin et
adjoint de leur professionnel de santé
par téléconsultation ce qui est en soi
une très bonne chose qui est à la fois
approuvée par les patients est approuvée
par les professionnels de santé
mais je pense que on doit travailler
dans ces périodes de crise à un accès
sécurisé à des soins et c'est peut-être
là qu'on doit renforcer l'information
des patients sur le fait qu'il ya des
gestes des actes des suivis qui sont
vraiment indispensables et qu'ils
doivent faire malgré tout la toute la
gravité de la situation sur la situation
en chine aujourd'hui on a très peu
d'informations mais effectivement les
chinois qui n'avait plus beaucoup de cas
on a géré un cluster à pékin et je crois
qu'ils gèrent de façon très volontariste
et sur geodis c'est un prestataire qui
est directement en lien avec santé
publique france donc je vous encourage
alors demandé directement parce que je
ne connais pas les de façon précise
comment ils ont ils ont interagi sur la
logistique
doit-on changer notre strate d'autres
stratégies pour d'autres virus de type
coronavirus doit-on tout de suite être
dans un dépistage massif dans un
tracking cpam la question vous posez sur
les courts en un virus elle est
terriblement compliqué parce que je vais
vous donner trois exemples le strass a
fait peur à tout le monde sais pas si
vous vous souvenez ya un effondrement du
trafic aérien
il ya 8000 cas 800 décès et ça s'est
arrêté
le maire ce code est très inquiétant
très létale mais il ne donne quasiment
pas d'épidémie il est toujours là ça
fait 5 ans 6 ans 7 ans qu'il est là
ville est toujours au moyen-orient sait
pas très bien quel est son réservoir de
temps en temps il ya une bouffée il ya
un cas secondaire il ya une épidémie
nosocomiales et ça s'arrête alors qu'il
était considéré comme inquiétant et
qu'il a d'ailleurs donné une épidémie
portante en corée et le coronavirus que
l'on que l'on affronte le sera ce kof 2
peu de virologues de lui donner entre
guillemets des chances pandémique mais
il s'avère qu'il est en train d'évoluer
alors pas forcément de muter un je suis
prudent mais d'évoluer de s'adapter
comme tous les virus
tous les russes font ça ils s'adaptent à
l'autre puisque c'est la seule façon de
survivre
et donc là aussi il faut qu'on soit très
attentifs à sa capacité à ce à attaquer
l'homme en termes de récepteur est ce
qu'il va à l'attaqué différents vous
avez vu qu'on compte que la
dexaméthasone était probablement le seul
traitement aujourd'hui qu'il parte qui
fonctionne ce n'est pas un être un anti
infectieux c'est un anti inflammatoire
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya aussi une
part inflammatoires très importante et
peut-être des terrains particulier des
susceptibilités génétiques des
fragilités qui font on réagit on sûr
réagi alain fiction en donnant ses
tableaux grave je pense qu'il faut qu'on
soit très modeste très humbles face à
nous ces incertitudes de scientifiques
et en particulier à nos noms
connaissance actuelle du virus mais
c'est très difficile de 2,2 de prévoir
ce que sera le suivant en sachant par
ailleurs je le rappelle qu'il ya
beaucoup de coronavirus chez l'homme au
moins cinq ou six se sont va dire entre
guillemets classique et bénin et c'est
peut être aussi ce qui explique la
faible proportion d'enfants touchés
c'est parce que ses enfants sont des
infections banales à coronavirus et
qu'ils ont entre guillemets jeu du jeu
mais bien les guillemets une immunité
croisés et donc qu'ils sont probablement
un peu plus capable de répondre
même s'il ya des enjeux de récepteurs et
qu'on peut en débattre longtemps avec le
plan blanc quasiment quasiment toutes
les opérations chirurgicales ont été
arrêtés dans notre pays ce qui aura sans
doute des conséquences mais en tout cas
c'est une réalité dont je souhaiterais
qu'à l'occasion de cette commission
denquête vous puissiez nous donner jour
par jour les stocks que vous aviez entre
le 1er janvier et maintenant sur deux
hypnotique le propofol et le midazolam
et sur trois que rare l'astra curium le
6 à tra curium et leurs corps omnium
aujourd'hui on nous dit que les
opérations chirurgicales ne peuvent pas
reprendre
faute de propofol est ce que vous le
confirmer ou pas
on nous dit qu'il faudrait deux mois
pour reconstituer les stocks de propofol
est ce que oui ou non vous le confirmer
ou pas et si à des stocks suffisants
pourquoi est ce que les opérations
chirurgicales ne reprennent pas est ce
que les plans blancs bloc continue à
tout bloquer oui ou non
merci donc des médicaments qui sont à la
fois utiles au bloc opératoire et est en
réanimation ce qui a probablement
surpris tout le monde sait à la fois que
les producteurs de ces produits mais
parfois c'est pas que des sujets de deux
producteurs eux-mêmes ces deux sujets
d'origine de la matière première se sont
retrouvés touché par la pandémie et
surtout que la crise a touché tout le
monde en même temps c'est à dire que les
besoins de réanimation ont été élevées
partout notamment en europe et donc nous
avons été très attentifs à suivre
évidemment ces médicaments critique pour
la réanimation dès le début et à faire
des points très régulier avec une
logistique aussi de crises l'air d'aller
chercher ses médicaments dans l'intérêt
des réanimateurs est dans l'intérêt
évidemment des chirurgiens donc ce que
je vous propose c'est que c'est
tellement précis que je vais vous donner
toutes tous les stocks
au quotidien on va vous préparer ça
parce que c'est très important et qu'on
a eu un suivi effectivement au quotidien
est une délivrance au quotidien parce
que c'était évidemment fondamental que
les médicaments soient disponibles au
lit du patient mais c'est effectivement
parce qu'il y a eu la déprogrammation et
plan blanc qu'on a pu accueillir c'est
plusieurs milliers de patients de
réanimation et augmenter les capacités
sans atteindre la ligne rouge mais c'est
aussi sur l'état des stocks à date qu'il
faut qu'on vous précise pourquoi on on
libère un certain nombre d'activités
chirurgicale qui n'ont pas forcément
recours à ces molécules
parce qu'on peut faire la chirurgie sans
d'utiliser ces molécules on la saisit
toutes les sociétés savantes
d'anesthésie-réanimation pour qu'elles
puissent proposer des alternatives et
puis ya aussi beaucoup de chirurgie qui
ne passe pas par la nsa général donc on
est attentif à ça c'est à dire à la fois
laissé les hôpitaux reprendre leurs
activités on a parlé des patients
chroniques mais être attentifs ou stocks
des médicaments critiques que vous avez
cités sur les prusse mon collègue je
sais plus je crois que mon collègue d'or
a posé la question tout à l'heure en
disant qu'il devait y avoir des alertes
un an avant et je crois que vous n'avez
pas répondu à ces questions est ce que
oui ou non avant qu'il soit réorganisé
ses alertes ont eu lieu ou pas à hadath
de un an avant
sur sur les différences top c'est la dgs
qui a demandé un état des stocks après
sur ce que disait très bien monsieur
d'or il ya un an je sais qu'on a eue sur
certains produits une absence de date de
péremption
il ne facilite pas les choses pour
donner une alerte donc quand on quand on
est et puis il ya des pharmaciens qui
connaissent très bien ça il sait les
pharmaciens qui sont les meilleurs
experts pour surveiller de très près les
stocks sont des gens extrêmement
rigoureux donc ils ont vraiment
l'habitude de le faire et ils sont très
attentifs en particulier aux médicaments
et la qualité des médicaments donc comme
il ya aussi des médicaments le stock
seul je peux vous garantir qu'ils sont
attentifs mais là on s'est retrouvé face
à cette difficulté qu'il était qu'on en
avait une
un énorme stock sans date et puis
effectivement que nous n'avons pas eu
d'alerté mais que nous avons eu cette
surprise lors de la demande de l'audit
dgs d'avoir une découverte de stock en
mauvaise qualité sur les curares et des
hypnotiques vous ne l'avez indiqué vous
avez centraliser les commandes je crois
ce qui a pu avoir un impact important
mais quand est ce que ce système de
contingentement va s'arrêter parce qu'il
semblerait que dans d'autres pays
voisins l'italie la suisse
il n'y a aujourd'hui plus du tout
difficultés d'approvisionnement et
certains médecins pointent plutôt un
problème bureaucratique de
centralisation qui les empêchent
d'obtenir eux mêmes ces produits qui
seraient disponibles je le dis au
conditionnel
je me permettrai sur importante de
vérifier mais je ne crois pas parce
qu'on est vraiment dans une démarche la
gestion des produits de santé c'est
quelque chose de très compliqué donc
encore plus sur les médicaments et
encore plus quand c'est des médicaments
d'importance vitale mais il ya une
démarche est vraiment européenne doit
être très très attentif parce qu'il peut
y avoir des alertes à un sujet de
pharmacovigilance un sujet de rupture de
stock quelque part donc en général ya
une vraie réponse européenne là je crois
que l'état joue son rôle dans la
commande massive et la régulation de
destop parce qu'on voulait être sûr
qu'il n'y ait pas des stocks qui
demeurent dans un endroit inutilisés et
puis des malades de l'autre côté qui
n'est pas accès à ces médicaments vous
avez évidemment par les déchirures de la
chirurgie donc on est vraiment attentif
et dès qu'on a ces stocks ont notre
seule obsession est de les fournir aux
professionnels donc
il faudra qu'on tire toutes les leçons
de cette logistique d'êta mais je crois
que là aussi et on en parlait tout à
l'heure avec les équipements de
protection individuelle la vraie
question qu'il faudra se poser sans
doute à l'avenir c'est doit-on disposer
de certains médicaments critique en plus
ou demande doit-on demander qu'il y ait
en permanence un stock de médicaments
sur certains médicaments ce qui n'est
pas quelque chose de facile parce qu'on
sait que c'est un sujet complexe en
général iv 750 millions de masques en
stock lorsque vous êtes arrivé environ
250 à 300 millions ont dû être jetés
brûlés et détruits
vous n'en commandé que 100 millions
assumez-vous d'avoir pris de risque
puisque vous vouliez un stock tournant
d'être démunis pendant deux ou trois ans
il ya eu effectivement cette destruction
il ya eu le choix d'avoir des stocks
tampons et des commandes régulières
il y à aussi savait ce qu'on avait
mobilisé je le veux je le précise raid
ans dans les dents les commandes on
avait mobilisé les producteurs français
parce que ça aussi c'est important que
pour pour avoir des précommandes et pour
les nous pour les mettre en tension et
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être l'occasion
aussi de les remercier
c'est à dire que je pense qu'il ya un
enjeu qui est tourné notre entre
guillemets jeu pas si c'est bon mot mais
qu'on ait notre capacité nationale de
production parce que c'est un c'est
important qu'on ait cette réflexion avec
eux plutôt que d'aller commander en
urgence à l'étranger que de se dire qu
elle l quels sont les besoins en france
régulier pour l'établissement de santé
pour la proximité et pour que nos
producteurs puissent savoir qu'elle est
là le besoin régulier dans des stocks
qui tourne à ce moment là régulièrement
au profit des professionnels de santé
des aliments de santé en masques
chirurgicaux et en masques ffp2 et donc
effectivement je pense que le
dimensionnement lui-même puisque nous
sommes en phase de commandes et les
modalités de fonctionnement de ce stock
doivent être interrogés vous nous avez
expliqué consommer consommer 200 à 250
millions de masques par an dans les
établissements de santé ou d'y
constituer un stock sont en peau vous ne
commander que 100 100 millions et puis
les autres années qui arrivent
d'ailleurs de business et 2000 va par
définition vous organisez vous notamment
ou pas une pénurie pour avoir un stock
roulant je pense que je me suis mal
exprimé
en faite le
le stock des établissements de santé est
géré directement par l'établissement ont
tenté c'est ce qu'on appelle le stock
tactique et ils ont leurs propres
commandes et ça fonctionne très bien au
quotidien donc il y a quel est le
dimensionnement de ce stock tactique est
ce qu'on doit demander l'établissement
d'avoir un peu plus que le
fonctionnement habituel et quel est ce
plus certains pays le font donc première
interrogation que je partage avec vous
et deuxièmement quel est le
dimensionnement réel du stock
stratégique en soutien et comment ils
fonctionnent correctement c'est à dire
comment est-ce qu'ils l'aident en appui
comment est-ce qu'ils participent du de
l'approvisionnement des établissements
de santé et des professionnels de santé
si vous voulez bien je vais louper les
trois dernières questions la première
c'est que on a cherché a commandé des
masques à l'étranger vous avez fait et à
plusieurs reprises des difficultés qu'on
avait eu à les obtenir
pourquoi ne peuvent être passés par les
importateurs on a vu que les centres
commerciaux ont été plus efficaces que
l'état plus rapide pour les obtenir
deuxième question pourquoi est ce que
alors qu'on devait prioriser des
personnels de santé
les ehpad ont eu l'autorisation de
recevoir des masques trois semaines à un
mois après ils n'étaient pas priorisées
en même temps que les médecins
hospitaliers alors qu'on sait il s'agit
de centres de lieux où les personnes les
plus fragiles sont par nature confiné où
une épidémie peut faire plus de dégâts
enfin on nous a expliqué que c'est vrai
mais ce qu'ils disaient que les masques
étaient inutiles pardon mais d'abord
notre propre plan prévoyait d'avoir des
stocks de masse dans les administrations
dans les entreprises dans les hôpitaux
j'imagine que c'est parce que
l'administration française ceux qui sont
chargés de prévoir les risques
sanitaires
donc le faisiez partie penser que ces
masques pouvait être utile sinon
pourquoi on prévoir dans le plan et
parce que le ms aurait dit que on en
avait pas besoin on n'utilise pas pardon
mais d'abord à ma connaissance le ms10
les gestes barrière et le masque vient
en plus donc ça ne veut pas dire
inutiles et en 2019 l'académie nationale
de médecine recommande le port du masque
haut conseil de santé publique dit je
cite la constitution d'un stock devrait
être considéré comme le paiement d'une
assurance que l'on souhaite malgré la
dépense sans jamais avoir besoin de
l'utiliser nous n'avions pas cette
assurance et nous sommes en train de le
payer très cher tant sur les trente
mille banking qui nous ont quittés que
sur les conséquences économiques et
sociales
il faut bien qu'à un moment donné nous
soyons capable de savoir pourquoi il n'y
a pas eu contrôle des stocks pourquoi il
n'y a pas eu renouvellement des stocks
c'est l'objet aussi de cette commission
d' enquête
pour que cela se reproduise pas dans ma
grande injustice du coup vous avez
bénéficié de 4 vous avez restauré la
justice fait trois minutes ce sont les
hôtes en 2045 merci madame la présidente
de votre gentillesse
merci à présent donc sur le circuit
distribution je le disais tout à l'heure
le disque une distribution quand ya eu
des déstockages à la fois depuis le
stock stratégique depuis les
importations depuis la production
nationale est évidemment destiné à
l'ensemble des acteurs de santé et donc
il ya eu effectivement des difficultés
de délivrance peut-être dans sur tout le
territoire mais n'y avait pas de volonté
de de stigmatiser un établissement
versus un autre est évidemment on a
toujours été très attentif à protéger
les personnes les plus vulnérables sur
le plan pandémie qui date de 2011
il ya beaucoup de différences je
pourrais en citer mais c'est évidemment
pas la même démarche puisqu'on est à la
fois sur une évaluation du nombre de
personnes qui seraient malades et qui
nécessiterait d'être d'être équipé et
puis il ya toute la déclinaison de
l'accès aux vaccins et des antiviraux et
malheureusement de l'avion ni va ni
vaccin ni antiviraux donc c'était une
particularité de ce coronavirus à la
fois son hétérogénéité des formes
asymptomatiques des formes graves estime
qu'on a que l'on a vécu et et vous avez
cité malheureusement le lourd bilan en
termes de morts et je redis peut-être
que j'ai pas été clair je partage
totalement ce que vous avez dit sur le
fait que le masque grand public est un
geste barrière supplémentaire je dis pas
qu'il faut le mettre de côté
je lui ai dit à plusieurs reprises donc
je pense qu'on nous avait on a la chance
à la fois d'avoir une production
française de masques de qualité qui sont
des masques réutilisables aph à faible
empreinte écologique à faible impact
carbone parce qu'en plus la production
locale de qualité donc tant mieux
les français sont en train de s'emparer
de ce geste qui est un geste barrière
complémentaires j'insiste beaucoup sur
le fait qu'il est complémentaire parce
que je voudrais pas que il y ait cette
tendance qu'on observe ailleurs et qu'on
apporte peut-être pas en salles en
france qui compte les gens portent un
masque qu'ils oublient tout le reste
mais oublie de se laver les mains ils se
rapprochent
il ya des contacts directs donc c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'il ya un enjeu
d'éducation
à la santé qui est partagé par nos
concitoyens et je le dis tout à l'heure
sur les solutions pour alcooliques qui
sont maintenant le quotidien des
français si le masque grand public peut
être dans le foyer des français pour
servir lorsqu'il y aura des malades
lorsqu'il aura des enfants malades parce
que les gens ont pris l'habitude de le
porter je pense que ce sera une
véritable avancée de santé publique
parce qu'on aura acquis un geste
barrière supplémentaire
est-ce que
[Musique]
vous diriez que vous avez été amené à
adapter votre discours sanitaires aux
moyens disponibles
c'est une des questions qui et qui sait
poser régulièrement à la faveur des
événements et on pourrait éventuellement
l'entendre mais à condition que ça se
soit peut être explicité deuxième
deuxième question comment avez vous dû
justement du coup gérer cette pénurie
qu'est les actes ont été pris pour
organiser la commande
l'approvisionnement des territoires
est-ce que parfois vous ne vous êtes pas
reposer sur finalement les commandes des
collectivités avec tous les aléas que
cela pouvait représenter les inégalités
potentiel sur le territoire en
approvisionnement donc voila moi je
m'interroge quand même sur la façon dont
les choses ont été faites sur la
massification des tests enfin est-ce que
vous pensez encore que pendant la phase
ii il fallait pratiquer la façon dont
vous l'avez fait avec une manière de
procéder qui justement ne n'allait pas
dans cette direction
et enfin monsieur le directeur général
j'attends quand même des réponses un peu
complémentaire sur l'idh roxy et
taureaux qui le traitement sur les tests
les essais cliniques ont été diligentées
leur interruption à quel moment est ce
que réellement tout ça était a été
lancée et est ce que le traitement
combiné azithromycine roque look cycle
rutyna a été réellement testé dans les
achats de masques à l'étranger
l'objectif était vraiment d'avoir des
quantités importantes on l'a bien dit
pour livrer 770 millions de masques
depuis le mois de mars nous avons
beaucoup sollicité des producteurs
français les producteurs français ont
fait des efforts considérables mais il
ne pouvait pas répondre à la demande
massive et qui était qui était celle du
mois de mars donc nous avons les deux
nous avons enfin les trois mêmes hommes
sont les stocks la production nationale
et les importations
donc là encore si nous pouvons
stabiliser une production nationale
c'est ce que nous avons souhaité de en
tout cas depuis 2018 qu'ils aient des
contacts réguliers et des commandes de
qu'ils puissent être des négociations
notamment sur sur le stock tampon sur
des précommandes sur les questions de
ceux dharréville donc adaptation
connaissances scientifiques
réponse effectivement aux tensions j'en
suis totalement conscient on a essayé de
répondre en urgence à toutes les
tensions que vous avez cités sur le rôle
locale et le rôle national je vous
propose de vous envoyer tout ce qu'on a
fait région par région parce qu'on a
répondu évidemment à des situations
différentes à des populations
différentes et a des incidences
différentes donc là encore il y avait
des contacts avec les présidents de
conseils départementaux avec des
présidents de région avec un certain
nombre de grands élus qui ont voulu
intervenir et qui eux aussi sont
intervenus donc à la fois avec les
commandes d'état les commandes des
collectivités les adaptations aux
besoins et donc là encore on était
rendant des échanges permanents avec les
acteurs de terrain et je pense que le
rôle le local était tout à fait
important pour alerter ou pour affiner
la demande et c'était le rôle de la
cellule logistique injustement que de
pouvoir répondre de façon précise à des
enjeux de délivrance sur le territoire
de deux de réponse aux commandes
spécifiques et à la situation locale sur
l'idh roxy chloroquine là aussi je vous
propose de vous envoyer tous les essais
parce que ça sera beaucoup plus précis
les dates de d'inclusion les dates
d'interruption les nombres d'inclusion
et à chaque fois qui a décidé parce
qu'il ya un comité indépendant qui
décide qu'on continue qu'on continue pas
comme il y avait une inclusion donc ça
on tient tous les tableaux je pense que
c'est en ligne d'ailleurs si vous le
souhaitez je crois que c'est en ligne
sur le site du ministère
à la fois le bilan complet des rosters
d'euros des recherches impliquant la
personne humaine parce qu'on a voulu que
ce soit transparent tous les protocoles
en cours sont en ligne mais si vous
voulez effectivement les dates ce sera
peut-être plus précis à l'est notamment
tous les bras c'est à dire qu'est ce
qu'il y avait dans chaque bras on parle
de bras quand on quand on teste un stand
d'hypothèses donc est-ce que c'était
hydroxy chloroquine seul est ce que
c'était de roxy chloroquine en
ambulatoire en curatif ou préventif chez
les malades graves avec ou sans
azithromycine donc que vous ayez toutes
les réponses notamment sur les doses
pour ce soit le plus précis possible
la question qui se pose c'est ce qu'on a
adapté le discours sur les masques à la
pénurie
c'est ça le fond de la question s'ils
voulaient qu'on essaye de creuser bon
alors d'abord vous avez une première
question à laquelle vous n'avez pas
répondu je ne comprends pas pourquoi
vous commandé des masques pour refaire
vos stocks
début février et moins de quinze jours
plus tard vous expédier des masques en
chine ce qui a pas une contradiction de
décès de reconstituer des stocks et de
l'autre d'aider son voisin deuxièmement
je ne comprends pas la contradiction
entre vos propos du 29 février
vous dites le port du masque n'est pas
la solution dans public à rebours
d'ailleurs de ce que vous avez répondu
tout à l'heure en disant vous avez
défendu cette solution là et le 22 avril
j'ai toujours plaidé pour l'accès aux
masques grand public donc à quel moment
est-ce que quelle est votre position est
ce que vous considériez que c'était
inefficace ou indispensable et à l'heure
où le monde se masquer en asie c'est une
stratégie lointaine mais aussi je vous
ai cité un certain nombre de pays
européens
comment se fait-il que nous ayons tant
tardé et enfin sur l'utilisation des
études du lan 7
je ne comprends pas pourquoi lorsque
lens est de fait une étude en 2020 sur
les docks cycle rockin le lendemain ou
le surlendemain on suspend le traitement
et quand vous avez une étude de 2003 qui
vous dit que le masque est plus
important plus efficace que tous les
autres gestes barrières on n'en tient
pas particulièrement content dans notre
stratégie
enfin vous avez également citer l'hymne
bayal college il y à un britannique qui
s'appelle roland salomone qui a révélé
que ce le modèle de l'ipa yann collette
j'avais était faux concernant la
pandémie de 2009
dans ces conditions pourquoi est ce que
nous avons
appliquer le modèle de libérer le
collège sans le critiquer est ce que le
fait que 1 et membre de l'ibal collègues
figure au comité scientifique a joué un
rôle dans cette absence de critique du
modèle c'est apparu dans le paysage
français
le modèle et à des défauts tout dépend
de paramètres qu'on lui donne donc on
peut se tromper sur un modèle dont on
peut aussi avoir un modèle qui répond
bien à la la prédiction de ce que l'on
observe donc je pense que c'est un à
nouveau à nouvel outil utile pour les
épidémiologistes et pour les
statisticiens et pour les décideurs que
d'avoir un modèle qui fonctionne et je
crois que le modèle français
je parle du modèle français des équipes
françaises il beaucoup de modélisateurs
français qui ont travaillé et qui ont
publié donc et de qualité après je ne
ferai pas de commentaire sur le modèle
anglais mais il ya des évaluations
indépendantes il ya un comité de deux
publications qui décide si oui ou non le
modèle est publié donc je pense que ça
c'est important sur le statut du match
en asie vous savez que c'est un masque
qui est utilisé pour de très nombreuses
occasions pour des alertes pollution
pour des épidémies et que cette entrée
dans l'est dans les moeurs très
largement mais on peut quand même noter
qu'il ya de toute façon une épidémie en
asie et que ce n'est pas si simple que
ça puisque même les autorités de
singapour ont des difficultés à la gérer
actuellement la chine gérera cluster
alors que le port du masque est
extrêmement répandu donc c'est pas
toujours si évident que ça et sur le sur
la priorité par par secteur je redis ce
que j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises dans
le temps mais dans mes prises de parole
la priorité dans en fin janvier et en
février c'était l'équipement des
personnels projeté donc les masques p2
que le voulait avoir pour les personnes
qui allaient gérer des cas graves qui
allait faire du transport de
l'évacuation et herat et ça me
paraissait important que ses équipes
soient protégés par des masques et p2 et
les équipements de protection
individuelle et donc c'était vraiment la
logique de prise en charge des clusters
de prise en charge des premiers cadets
prise en charge des patients de
réanimation ça c'était le monde
mon premier cercle deuxième siècle
ensuite a été de prendre en charge
autour des clusters vous souvenez
contamines montjoie on a géré les
parents les contacts les enfants qui
étaient autour de ce goût de ce contact
et puis après il ya eu un énorme débat
on peut on peut le refaire et puis je
vous donnerai les les références
scientifiques sur faut-il aller plus
loin
dans le masque grand public il ya eu des
questions qui m'ont été posées
effectivement vous pouvez reprendre les
questions en direct à la presse
peut-être que j'ai pas été assez claire
les gens me disais mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait pas comme dans d'autres pays
où tout le monde dehors à démasquer moi
j'ai dit dehors dans les masques je ne
vois pas l'intérêt parce que c'est ce
qu'on dit encore aujourd'hui les vrais
indications du port du masque et c'est
un peu ce qu'on aurait pu vivre ce soir
c'est c'est quand on est dans un espace
clos quand les gens ne n'arrive pas à
respecter les gestes barrières quand on
est trop proche qui a trop de monde et
donc les lèveraient message que je veux
faire passer c'est que en situation
promiscuité dans des transports publics
par exemple quand on peut pas respecter
les barrières
là il ya une vraie indication au port du
masque devant public et comme les
français s'en sont emparés et qu'il ya
une production de masse que non publique
je soutiens évidemment cette utilisation
comme geste d'arrière complémentaires il
me semble que l'hydroxyde chloroquine
n'a toujours été réservé et redit depuis
ces deux décrets en effet aux patients
hospitalisés vous aviez été sollicité
par le président de la camsa qui médecin
généraliste pour faire une tout cas
utiliser l'hydroxyde chloroquine chez
les soignants insectes et 7,7
sollicitations n'a jamais été suivies
d'effet deuxièmement en alsace sur le
territoire notamment de strasbourg il y
avait un protocole indiquant en tout cas
un parcours patient qui pouvait être
fait de façon très coordonnée entre le
public et le privé et permettent
notamment à des cliniques privées
d'intervenir je suis moi même intervenu
auprès de la nouvelle directrice
d'agencé régionale de santé qui m'a dit
que ce n'était absolument pas de sa
compétence que de prendre la moindre
initiative et qu'elle attendait tout
l'est en tout cas les indications et les
orientations qui devait venir du
ministère de la santé ou de la direction
générale de la santé
donc là également il n'y a pas eu de
suite
on a vraiment fermé aucun protocole
ambulatoire aucun protocole de ville
puisqu'il ya même eu des protocoles
cliniques qui ont eu lieu donc aucune
aucune décision d'être des traîtres
contre des protocoles notamment portée
par des médecins généralistes
il ya peut-être eu ensuite des analyses
en cpp ou en online et celles qui ont
considéré que l'étude ne
n'était pas à même d'aller au bout mais
enfin il n'y a pas de doctrine contre le
médecin généraliste ou de crimes contre
les essais de roxy chloroquine en ville
il y en a eu donc dans la liste qu'on va
vous faire parvenir et vous verrez qu'il
y ait calé et c'est qu'ils contiennent
cette ouverture aux médecins
généralistes
vous avez dit que pour le port du masque
obligatoire n'était pas obligatoire dans
les différents rapports que j'ai
effectués sur les risques épidémiques eu
l'occasion d'expérimenter la schl à la
chine la corée du sud le vietnam et hong
kong
dans ces pays là c'est une culture
traditionnelle de mettre le masque dès
l'instant où il y à un risque évidemment
il ya la pollution mais si les risques
viraux donc on voit les résultats les
résultats sur la corée du sud seront
hong kong et sur le vietnam s'est
quasiment très peu de décès et très peu
d'altération individuel donc pourquoi ne
l'avons nous pas effectué la deuxième
question vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
la commande des masques à l'étranger je
ne sais pas si vous avez été dans ce
dans ce sujet là mais en 2013 lorsqu'il
ya eu la doctrine de changement de
technique on a lancé les commandes en
chine et non plus en france alors qu'en
2011 le plan pandémie avait construit ou
fabriquer les les masses dans quatre
entreprises françaises dont une bretonne
qui s'appelait bacou dalloz
ensuite comme c'était parti en chine les
entreprises françaises ont fermé la
porte dans une d'ailleurs été mise en
liquidation judiciaire avec des
problèmes difficiles avec les employés
qui maintenant poursuivre le patron et
le présent de la république a décidé de
rouvrir ces entreprises françaises
méchant pense peut-être trop tard donc
ces deux mois que je voudrais savoir
pourquoi on a abandonné les entreprises
françaises en 2013 2014
merci beaucoup alors sur les
comparaisons internationales et sur la
culture du masque je pense qu'il faut
qu'on prenne le temps de bien regarder
effectivement parce que vous l'avez déjà
fait mais je sais qu'il s'est passé
beaucoup de choses
récemment qui ont permis d'interpeller
les spécialistes dire à la fois peu de
cas dans la péninsule d'asie du sud est
est ce nom sait pas très bien pourquoi 6
et d'humidité aussi ou où la chaleur on
ne compte qu a quand même été touché
comme singapour alors que là ce sont des
des lieux où la discipline du port du
masque est très important et puis la
chine a connu quand même une épidémie
tout à fait majeur avec un confinement
majeur oui mais avec un vraiment une
compliance au port du masque est très
importante je pense qu'ils voient qu'on
prenne le temps de regarder les
comparaisons internationales et pourquoi
ça s'est bien passé dans certains
endroits est moins bien dans d'autres ce
que je disais tout à l'heure et chauve à
la main c'est à dire que je pense que si
les foyers français s'équipent de leurs
masques au tissu fabriqué en france on
aura on aura avancé dans l'âme dans la
culture du risque et tant mieux et je
pense que ça fera partie du quotidien
des français que d'avoir éventuellement
une boîte de masques en tissu qui soit
utilisable pour les prochains pour les
prochaines alerte sur sur l'évolution
2011 et les commandes qui ont ensuite
suivi moi je le vois je ne crois
vraiment pas y avoir contribué donc je
regarderai si vous le voulez bien
pourquoi on a commandé et uk où on a
commandé quel a été le sourcing et
s'était même beaucoup avant de des
commandes donc on vous fera peut-être un
tableau très précis de toutes les
commandes des années 2000 et 2010 pour
savoir
voilà c'est pourquoi on a effectivement
choisi un certain nombre d'entreprises
n'est pas d'autres
mais vous avez vu que là il ya eu un
magnifique une magnifique mobilisation
des entreprises entreprises françaises
avec une production tout à fait
significatives en mousse mais on va
regarder les dates effectivement et on
vous fera un tableau comparatif précis
si vous le voulez bien à la présidente
je voudrais juste que monsieur d'ériger
un vous répondez sur votre déclaration
du 17
du 17 mars où vous dites qu en
circulation at il eu tests pcr n'a pas
beaucoup d'intérêt aucun pays l'a fait
c'est pas honteux de me dire que vous
avez évolué et ce dans les jours qui ont
suivi sur votre avis sur cherche pas à
vous faire des problèmes cherche juste à
comprendre pourrait aussi pourquoi vous
avez attendu 5 avril pour libérer ces
énergies qui venait des pcr
universitaire ou du monde vétérinaire
etc
il ya un gros gros délais et pendant ce
temps là il y avait un seul hôpital qui
fait un quart du volume des thèses pc
r de toute la france qui était marseille
donc je veux juste que vous me répondiez
là dessus juste un petit mot sur sur les
masques je veux être comme vous vous
encensez beaucoup le mas grand public
avec les normes afnor dans ma forme
c'est une simplification la norme pays
peu plus tolérante
il n'y a pas mille tests de la
filtration bactérienne ni de tests de
filtrer sont virales comme sur la norme
médicale le n 14 681 3 qui est la norme
pour l'image chirurgicaux donc pour le
moment vous n'avez aucunement la
certitude que ces masque en tissu sont
de bons éléments filtrant pour ce qu'on
veut dans le cadre de la prévention de
transmission de gouttelettes de plus que
de grosses gouttes lettres ou de petit
goût doux de petits aérosols
transportant des virions c'est important
que la population elle et ça en tête
cette norme n'a été fait dans l'urgence
elle est extrêmement tolérante et
aujourd'hui rien ne garantit qu'elle
protège contre la transmission du virus
les bactéries chest l'hôpital a quitté
le monde du tissu depuis bien longtemps
pour passer sur le les médias filtrants
non tissés j'aimerais que vous me
répondez sur une potentielle évolution
de ces normes pour s'adapter à un
contexte épidémiologique
mais la question c'est est effectivement
pourquoi ne pas tester tout le monde est
en pratique que j'ai insisté à ce moment
là sur l'importance de se tester quand
on était symptomatique et on avait
beaucoup de symptomatique qui ne se
testait pas en disant c'est bénin j'ai
juste mal à la gorge et 38 je ne veux
pas faire de telles sont c'est pour ça
que j'ai insisté sur le fait qu'il
fallait insister sur les porter sur les
symptomatique et dire cela il faut y
aller parce que beaucoup de gens ne
voulaient pas y aller se disait qu'ils
étaient positifs il était en isolé que
leurs proches seraient isolés qu'ils
auraient des problèmes professionnels
dont c'était cette émotion de ce
contexte là donc je je je
j'accorde que quand on prend l'homme a
répond ça peut surprendre et aujourd'hui
je le redis toutes les personnes
symptomatique toutes les personnes qui
ont un doute toutes les personnes qui
veulent protéger leur entourage qui ont
des fragiles dans leur entourage qui ont
des contacts qui ont qui sont dans un
cluster qui sont à distance de la boe
qu'on va chercher ce cri qui ont des
facteurs de risque il faut vraiment
aller au test et on a des capacités qui
sont pas utilisés donc je partage
totalement votre analyse sur la norme
des masques grand public ce que je vous
propose c'est plutôt de renvoyer parce
que c'est pas un masque sanitaire sur le
sur bercy qui a mis en place qui a fait
un énorme travail de dge particulier de
production française de ces matchs
je ce ne sont pas des masques sanitaires
aux normes sanitaires c'est pas des
masques ffp2 on est d'accord mais c'est
comme des masques réellement filtrants
et ça a été testée donc on vous donnera
peut-être un descriptif part merci de ce
que qu'on a regardé parce que je
voudrais pas donner l'impression que
c'est parce que c'est pas un masque
sanitaire ça n'a aucun doute une
efficacité
ce qui serait quand même
contre-productif et ce qui n'est pas le
cas donc on vous fournira les détails
techniques
là ma question c'est on travaille
toujours au 16 janvier en situation
dégradée
ma question est simple jusqu'à quand à
partir de quel moment va travailler en
situation normale avec des surblouse
normale et des gants normaux et des
masques ne me va pas quand est-ce que ça
va s'arrêter cette ce mode dégradé alors
j'ai essayé d'y répondre mais peut-être
que je n'ai pas été très clair vous avez
raison j'ai connu effectivement on a
commandé des équipements de protection
individuelle de 30 janvier
on a eu des tensions très fortes aux
équipements de protection individuelle
vous les connaissez vous les avez cités
et donc c'est ce qui encourage 9 d'abord
le fait qu'on continue à en commander et
que là on a on a maintenant deux des
arrivées massives de massage vous et je
vous ai parlé des ponts aériens des
livraisons mais même chose je partage
votre votre point de vue s'il ya une
vraie interrogation sur ne faut-il pas
que ces équipements de protection
individuelle dont on voit l'importance
sur vous sur chaussures protection
lunettes etc ne rentre pas dans le stock
stratégique pour qu'on ait en permanence
cet accès est qu'il n'y ait pas
effectivement des conditions dégradées
pour l'espagne et quand même un moment
où il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
voulaient se faire tester qui était
symptomatique et qui n'ont pas pu le
faire et on leur disait restez chez vous
parce qu'on n'a pas la possibilité de le
faire ça c'est quand même une réalité
est-ce qu'on reconnaît ensemble cette
réalité la deuxième chose sur la
question des masques est ce que j'ai
entendu ce que vous avez expliqué par
rapport à votre doctrine mais est-ce que
vous reconnaissez que à un moment donné
on peut considérer qu'il ya une pénurie
est ce que le mot pénurie pour vous êtes
un gros mot à mot galvaudé ou est ce que
c'est une réalité qui a eu lieu il ya
quel peut-être quelques jours mais est
ce que est ce que ça a été cette réalité
là ce que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
par rapport à votre doctrine sur les
stocks tampons nous avait précisé
ça nécessite des commandes rapides et
que donc est-ce qu'on vende vous êtes
posé la question mais est-ce que si on
dépend de la chine et que la chine est
attaqué en premier sur sur l'épidémie
est-ce que du coup cette condition des
commandes rapides les plus rapides et
n'est plus remplie et donc comment faire
face à ça et enfin juste pour terminer
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
finalement un regret que vous avez dans
cette crise un regret que vous avez par
rapport laisse y en est peut-être une
mesure concrète que vous proposez à la
représentation nationale pour une
prochaine crise sur les tests
effectivement ce que je vous ai dit
c'est qu'on a évité en collectivement
avec les experts à passer d'une
surveillance syndromique épidémies
telles qu on le fait souvent c'est à
dire on a le les médecins sentinelles et
mesah généralistes les surveillances on
sait qu'on a dit qu'à part cabinet face
et ça permet de surveiller il n'y a pas
forcément d'impact thérapeutique
particulier donc entre cette demande là
de dire est ce que finalement qu'en que
chacun est malade il a un test
et puis finalement la réalité
d'aujourd'hui où on a la capacité mais
finalement les personnes ont du mal à
aller vers le laboratoire parce que il
ya peut être beaucoup de beaucoup
d'explications voilà je pense que là il
ya eu un ajustement et qu'on aurait pu
être peut-être plus pédagogue je le
conçois que tu as fait je ne conseille
tout à fait sûr le les très fortes
tensions je les partage
ça a été très compliqué vous avez vu
qu'il ya des enjeux logistique mettre en
place un tel pont aérien puis ensuite
une délivrance ou plus près sur les j'ai
acheté sur les officines c'est quelque
chose de les dire d'inédits et je pense
que les gens ont vraiment bossé une
nuitée jours ça a été compliqué pour
tout le monde mais effectivement il
fallait répondre aux urgences et en
particulier le territoire qui étaient
les plus touchés soit les commandes
rapides vous avez raison c'est à dire
qu'on pratique on a ce qui se passe tous
les jours et ça se passe très bien et on
n'a pas forcément besoin de l'art des
stocks immense parce que ça répond et
puis là une situation totalement inédite
où un pays le plus gros pays se
retrouvent à l'arrêt ce qui est quand
même pas du tout ce qui dope que
personne n'avait pu imaginer et donc
avec à la fois des chutes de production
et des besoins majeurs pour lui m donc
effectivement je pense que ça fera
partie du de ce qu'on pourra de ce qu'on
pourra imaginer pour le dit alors ce
qu'on peut dire ensuite pour la suite
beaucoup de choses je pense qu'on
partage qu'on a dit tout à l'heure sur
les autres pays je pense que ces
équipements de protection individuelle
vous l'avez dit maintenant la députée ça
doit être quelque chose qui fait partie
du quotidien des soignants et qu'on doit
fournet de façon beaucoup plus
importante vous avez parlé de de
certains médicaments critique tout à
l'heure je pense que c'est la même chose
donc moi ce que je dirais c'est qu'il ya
plusieurs enjeux il ya l'enjeu pour moi
et pour la ds générale de la santé de
tirer toutes les leçons je pense qu'il
va falloir être très transparent en
toute humilité parce qu'il faut qu'on se
prépare un rebond et une deuxième vague
il ya quand même des points positifs
c'est qu'aujourd'hui avec les commandes
avec le pont aérien on va avoir beaucoup
plus de masques de je parle de masques
soignants parle de masques chirurgicaux
et il ya maintenant des quantités
importantes de masques en stock dans les
établissements de santé c'est une bonne
nouvelle
l'accès au test je partage le fait
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on ait un
discours très offensif pour traquer le
virus là où il est c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une circulation
beaucoup plus faibles il faut il faut
aller le chercher il y as peut-être à
discuter des enjeux logistique qui n'ont
pas été faciles surtout l'ensemble du
territoire avec ces circonstances
exceptionnelles
je crois qu'on peut apprendre beaucoup
de la surveillance des ehpad je pense
que c'est un dispositif qu'il faut
renforcer je pense qu'on peut apprendre
qu'on peut développer beaucoup les
certificats électroniques de décès qui
nous permet de savoir en temps réel ce
qui se passe et quelles sont les causes
de décès et puis bal à la pédagogie où
je peux certainement améliorer les
choses pourquoi on passe d'une dépistage
individuel à une stratégie de dépistage
général la place des masques et quel
sera l'avenir de ces masque en tissu par
exemple ou d'enlever au sein des foyers
français ils le périmètre
le périmètre du stock stratégique qu'est
ce qu'on veut en faire collectivement et
la place du stratégique par rapport au
stock tactique je voudrais revenir sur
lille roxy chloroquine vous évoquiez
effectivement le risque que celles ci
soient utilisés en automédication je
peux l'entendre
en revanche il me semble qu'il y à
d'autres façons notamment par exemple de
liste et la molécule plutôt que
d'interdire la prescription des médecins
et je voulais savoir ce qui avait motivé
cette interdiction de prescription par
ailleurs j'ai entendu tout à l'heure que
vous aviez évoqué le souhait de
relocaliser la production de masques en
france et j'ai le sentiment que il y a
tout de même un manque de stratégie
majeur
lorsqu'on sait que en 2018 faute de
commandes
la dernière usine française de
production de masques qui était basé à
plaintel a fermé ses portes
par manque de commandes alors qu'elle
comptait encore 200 employés en 2017
alors essentiellement regard du coût
puisque cela avait été évoqué je serais
curieuse de savoir aujourd'hui le coût
généré par l'achat de masques en chine
avec des ponts aériens
parce que je suppose que le coup est
très largement majorées par rapport au
coût qui avait été évoqué à l'époque
et puis également cela a été évoqué je
pense que dans le cas d'une pandémie il
est nécessaire d'être réactif or là nous
perdons tout réactivité et nous créons
une vraie dépendance par rapport à la
chine
il me semble qu'il s'agit d'une vision à
très court terme
en fait on a quand même des coopérations
internationales qui sont extrêmement
importantes dans les deux sens
la chine nous a beaucoup aidés nous
aidons quand nous pouvons quand il ya
des demandes que ce soit au niveau
européen je signale par exemple que nous
avons aidé l'italie l'italie nous a aidé
l'allemagne nous a été donc il ya eu
quand même une magnifique solidarité
internationale et notamment pour le
grand est
il ya eu beaucoup d'évacuation vers
luxembourg à l'allemagne car c'est quand
même des baux signes de coopération donc
de que de montrer qu'on peut et ont
possédé de temps en temps entre pays
j'entends votre votre demande et
d'ailleurs ça correspond à une demande
de monsieur d'or donc si vous me
permettez je ferai aussi c'est à dire
quoi on vous expliquera exactement ce
comment en est on à isques on a analysé
cet enjeu de de stock régulier de
commandes régulières parce que c'est ce
que demandent les producteurs c'est que
ya pas une commande tous les cinq ans il
faut qu'on ait justement ce stock
tournant c'est ça ça va avec la demande
qu'on avait avec santé publique france
qui est des commandes régulières pour
les établissements de santé pour le
stock stratégique pour qu'ils aient une
visibilité pour les producteurs français
qui sache
de combien de masque on a besoin après
je suis d'accord avec vous qui est un
enjeu de proximité c'est sur le coup je
ne sais pas je vous répondrais
précisément par contre sur la réactivité
ce n'est pas toujours évident parce que
vous avez un
une demande très basses en permanence
parce que ça tourne à 3 ou 4 millions de
masques et puis à les stocks et là on a
eu une telle demande brutal qu'il ya
aussi un enjeu de réactivité des chaînes
qui n'est pas évidente même pour les
producteurs français qui nous ont
signalé qu'il avait dû totalement changé
leurs capacités de production totalement
changé leurs chaînes rééquiper des
chaînes embauché enfin voilà il ya
toujours la question de comment on
répond en urgence à un besoin massif et
ça je pense que quel que soit le
producteur c'est c'est une question
importante lors du coude pour la chine
est ce que vous pouvez me dire
exactement combien de masques ont été
donnés dans le cadre de cette solidarité
je comprends qu'il ya une solidarité
mais si on n'a pas de veste pour
soi-même il dit les dommages peut-être
de prêter la dernière qui nous restent à
son voisin donc ce qu'on pouvait nous
expliquer la rationalité je voudrais les
chiffres précis mais ces quelques
centaines de milliers de masques et en
pratique ça fait partie des protocoles
internationaux de coopération du
ministère des affaires étrangères est
très sensible au fait qu'on réponde et
en plus c'est une doctrine oms c'est à
dire qu'en fait quand il ya une demande
de de réponse en urgence dans un endroit
où il ya un foyer on l'a fait pour ebola
on a fait pour d'autres
notre crise on sait que ça répond tout
de suite que ça permet de te contenir la
plupart du temps en sommes dans neuf cas
sur dix neuf foyers et que ça permet
d'éviter aux autres pays d'avoir à gérer
le même risque que c'était logique et
puis je crois qu'en plus la chine nous a
vraiment massivement idée derrière et
donc il ya un retour aussi pour la
france tout à fait significatif dans la
priorité qui a donné la chine
assez assez acheminement vers la france
sur la commande de masques mais 100
millions vous commandez que 100 des
publics france commande sur vote vos
instructions est-ce que ce choix relève
de votre seule décision je vous que je
vous confirme effectivement qu'on a bien
commandé 100 millions de masques en
octobre 2018 que l'idée était d'être
très rapidement sur une évolution
puisqu'on attendait début 2020 d'une
organisation complètement différentes
qui étaient des précommandes une
de favoriser les producteurs français
est que d'avoir une réévaluation
complète justement de ce qu'on appelait
avec eux françois bourdillon qui avait
proposé cela un stock tournant et un
stock tampon donc c'était cette
organisation là il y avait des enjeux de
précommande
et puis il y avait probablement à cette
époque ça je le dis en toute modestie
pas du tout cette connaissance qu'on a
aujourd'hui des besoins considérables
d'une épidémie c'était donc l'audition
de jérôme salomon le monde entier a été
surpris par cette crise totalement
inédite massive rapide brutale et
mondial a martelé l'actuel directeur
général de la santé qui a cependant
défendu ses services et la réactivité du
pays face à l'épidémie
cette audition et toutes celles de la
commission denquête sont à retrouver
tout l'été sur lcp et sur notre site
lci.fr